RG&E what did you want we don't have
much time Cal Darius your jailers are
coming so here's the deal we get you out
of here alive and you help us kill r in
Dane hey I don't need your help I might
need your help
I started as early as myself to my soul
fridge Power Cells was supposed to be
recharged and the Cecilia's power badly
ruin if that settlement was built like
the other bliss colonies there should be
a backup source oh I'm playing it up yep
there he is nice thick uh something make
it all right nice i'll just set the
store oh the other they're kind of
making it easily like wait wake up these
guys
oh man that's a lot
how about that dude
right yes then
when there's a bunch of guys I feel
something
second
is that it oh there's like one guy that
it yes no yeah X wave is alright
I think they might have taken out known
looks like all the turrets yeah what do
we do with all that stuff
sure oh here they come again that same
door just so gay yeah i mean just gonna
go sweet what's there and throw that
whoa
what the ships
the content from the other night between
320
I'm going the other guard
they were regulating the sports oh hey
hey hey
hi
Oh
him
ok
what's happening on the other side I
think they're on the roof pad on the
roof oh those are this guy's heavy
damage sustained the engineering cool uh
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
working on the couple iterated
yes she does he ran away from the car
this rocket not promise I'll leave you
alone oh yeah
forget Nick I said uh all right towards
look it's better yeah
yeah there's a little spunk singing up
top give me that rocket shooting yeah
oh yeah
hey come on in my bigger concern just
break your doors
gotta watch around I read those gorgeous
fellow
oh there's a one of these things I'm not
the 14 all the schools this year here
there's one over here yeah puppet unison
furrows runs are pretty good just
because you need to soak all the stuff
down whoops whoo there's a guy
hi all right you're the worst no
seriously I had these plans honor thing
today I don't know there's no line on
some French hours to please this is the
last napping service I did it I guess if
you want something killed right you
gotta kill yes
ok sharks
what
we go throw everything to keep this
rocket that promise I'll leave you alone
oh my god